hello guys oh hi I'm Rebecca I'm from
Philadelphia and I'm studying in Berlin
for a semester here monet's I live in
Kreuzberg my favorite area Berlin is a
great city because you can discover new
things here every day with noise and
duck and Cod well today I want to
discover some things with you Robin and
I yet
let's go the shout look at these
buildings aren't they beautiful
I love the architecture in the balconies
they're all seamlessly connected with no
gaps in Philadelphia in Philadelphia
it's unusual for students to live in the
middle of the city here I live in a
magnificent building back home I live on
campus in a dormitory with other
students Evanston
Nero togas och dusty berry must I've
been told that Bergman Strasse was the
first street in Berlin to have a string
of shops cafes and restaurants all the
way down one after the other cheeks and
cafes encuesta haunt in Thailand
Thursday and understand it's true when
you look down the street you just see
shops and things is very complex so
lively there's always something going on
here there you go and I thought I'm of
Oslo's here
judge pd+ Fodor she does today mean it
looks just like Berlin dialect can you
tell me what it means real inner yeah
okay the letters stand for a phrase that
means far far away done slice close ah
okay oh but shouldn't that first let her
be Ajith bullion's
fight Clausen Y on the we Berliners
pronounce it with a J sound good guns
life both manioc Diego I would never
figure that out even if you know German
the Berlin dialect is like a completely
different language Foskey Anna Anna her
swaha is much well this is my favorite
place in Berlin the former Tempelhof
airfield
leave us here I love it here it's not
like a normal Park it feels like being
in a community there's something for
everyone so let's get to echo for ye man
can hear this you can play frisbee jog
have a picnic picnic muffin does is
y'all bit sick that's funny plants
growing in shoes hey I'm gonna take a
picture of that - is dusty the thing is
you can do whatever you like in Temple
overfilled I think it's great type of
Oliver fell beneath said and us annex
all huh
why do they're supposed to be a good bar
here although yeah well everyone knows
there are loads of cool places to go in
Berlin someone told me the solar bar was
especially good fallen because of the
view finishing I'll split off Berlin to
be eaten hot
dumb so it's right hidden away
Plus isn't this great look at the
panorama
let's run tota abscissa what a great way
to end a fantastic day I hope you liked
our walk through the city I can only
think of one way to sum it up Kevyn Orr
driver to $3 Catherine
I love you Berlin
you